good question in case you didn't catch
it the question was about the accuracy
of the graph and your reliance on that
accuracy okay the short answer is I'm
actually even though I made a point that
my graphs at Wooster so you can
highlight in their IPC you don't need to
what's more important is that you
recognize things like this right and the
fact that a half root 3 or - 100 -
they're trying to see them to you
there's some exact value okay now if it
is not any one of those three or 103 if
you're looking at ten I should point out
by the way all on the reference you
they're all bad you can see them on the
triangles if it's not something like
that if I said oh no this so that's
clearly not going to be an exact value
I'm not going to trying to read that off
with my ground I'm just going to go to
my calculator up and I'm gonna do this
to give me whatever angle it is supposed
to be and then I'll just use that in the
same way that I used it before in fact
let's just do it right now um can you
tell me go ahead and punch this in for
the set of aha can you put in whatever -
whatever it
seven the grace let's just let's just do
it to the nearest degree that's fine
okay
so what I'm gonna say is oh my first
solution is going to be at seven degrees
right so if that's a half then there's
an eighth or there abouts okay so that's
seven degrees that way how do I get the
other solution will be 180 minus 7
degrees right so from the graphic age
will be 7 degrees or 180 take away 7
degrees and then is my insolent okay so
the vast majority of these the
overwhelming number will be these exact
values but if they're not you just find
out what the numbers supposed to be okay
now with all of this still on the board
I'm not gonna wipe it off because I know
some of you have been sort of watching
carefully so you can rise and light up
but just really quickly I want to show
you the versatility of each of these
methods if I just tweaked another video
okay so for instance let's that's all on
the same boy I'm gonna solve let me
think about it
let's go sine x equals minus root 3 on 2
okay sine X T was 2 minus root 2 all
right now what I have a look at this
again it's an exact value right I can
come in here come in here and I can say
- llúria - that's gonna be on the bottom
half of the circle isn't it - root 3 I
happen to notice about 1.7 I think if
you punch this in you'll get negative
0.866 whatever it is okay
that's what negative root 3 on to reason
so I'm just going to draw that somewhere
about there
okay do you see I don't need to think
about ASTC or anything like that in
which which which courgettes have
negative sign or anything like that
think the circle just takes care of for
me you know I had in the third and
fourth quadrants which is what I would
have known if I was really good at using
this and it didn't make any mistakes but
I didn't need to know it I just draw the
line okay and then I said okay what
angle will get me to this I've got to go
all the way around until I get into this
triangle right so let's have a look y
equals mass returns me he is root three
on to the radius of course is he's the
theater I'm after
okay so sine theta equals root 3 on 2
once the exact egg would look at the
size of it that's gonna be 60 right if
it's an exact angle it's clearly passed
like the halfway point and it wasn't
this small angle before okay so I can
say theta is equal to 60 but where do
you start counting from on the unit
circle
you don't start count from anywhere you
like you start counting from here don't
you so I'm gonna go all the way around
90 degrees 180 degrees plus 60 gives me
240 degrees right but look wait there's
another solution there use that guy how
do I get to here
well the unit circle is symmetrical
isn't it so this theater which you told
me was sixty degrees over here I think
it's still sixty degrees over here so
how far do I have to go all the way
around if you get to this spot answer
360 take away that last bit right which
is 300 and you go ahead and pop into
your calculator I'll sign to 40 more
sign 300 and it will tell you negative
root 3 over 2 oh you couldn't have given
me a better segue to finish this the
summary you remember I excited off this
lesson for those who who were here I was
like I just may not 130-150 39510 how
was I doing that okay he's how I was
doing the UM the trig functions remember
I only grafts this pocket from naught to
360 but he just keeps going
they just he just keeps doing his merrie
thing you have a special word for this
it starts with a P right we call this a
periodic function because it repeats
every its periods 200 C degrees now have
a look at my original why it was a half
life if I were to extend the domain 0 to
7 2002 1080 or whatever I like okay I
can see my graphs just gonna go further
so I'm gonna get that's 390 right there
that's 510 can someone tell me how I
knew is 390 because it's the same copy
every 360 degrees every 360 so if I had
an answer of 30
I'll have another answer 360 degrees
later which is 390 if I've got an answer
at 150 I'll have another answer 360
degrees later which is 510 and on and on
forever
okay there are other ways that I can
adjust this for example I couldn't give
you this
okay now if you recall what this does
here is it makes sine wave around faster
right it's gonna wave around twice as
fast okay so you're gonna get solutions
that look like this I'm running out of
board space from naught to 360 instead
of just getting one copy I'm gonna get
two copies like this one too that's
really I think that I'm still gonna
thread through y equals a half like so
like that okay now because it's the same
graph squashed in twice as dense right
remember how last time we've got answers
at 30 and 150 31 150 well I squashed
that down so it takes up half the space
now so guess what that's not gonna be
that's not gonna be 30 anymore is it
it's gonna be 15 and then this is not
gonna be 150 anymore it's gonna be 75
okay and here's the cool thing right
remember how I said this had a period of
what we'll compute it in 360 degrees
right well I just took the whole thing
and I squashed it down so it's a top two
space so the period isn't 360 anymore
it's 180 is half the space so if this is
an answer I'll get another answer 180
degrees later which is 195 right and if
this was an answer I will get another
one 180 degrees later which is 250 and I
can keep on doing this forever if I want
so I'm going to pause there exercise 4 C
3 C 4 C 4 sit okay it's time to look at
these I don't think did I sign questions
under I don't think I did right because
I you were mostly working for a phobia
so I'm going to assign them now you use
whichever method you feel comfortable
with if you're like good oh I'm cozy
here this works for me I'm not gonna
tear you away from it but I am gonna
warn the unit circles not going away and
graphing is not going away okay
so if you're leading away from them
because you're uncomfortable with those
methods it's time to start working on
those methods until you do become cool
okay